[Applaudissements]
je sais pas vous mais moi je suis très
mauvaise perdante
ne le dit à personne j'allais jusqu'à
tricher au jeu de société pour gagner
c'était l'enfer pour ma famille
j'ai 6 ans 6 mois de karaté c'est ma
première compétition je suis en train
d'exécuter mon kata un ensemble de
mouvements codifié
je m'arrête en plein milieu trou de
mémoire je suis disqualifié je parle à
compétition
je me dirige vers ma maman pour trouver
un petit peu de réconfort et elle
m'accueille très froidement
c'est bien fait pour toi tu n'avais qu'à
te rappeler ton kata avec cette tête là
dure n'est-ce pas comme réaction j'avais
6 ans
cette scène je l'ai raconté tellement de
fois je me rappelle comme si c'était
hier
mais aujourd'hui maman j'ai envie de te
dire merci
pourquoi parce que cet événement a été
mon moteur j'ai ressenti une telle rage
une telle colère contre ma maman contre
moi-même et en bonne mauvaise perdante
j'ai développé une aversion de la
défaite bon pour être tout à fait
honnête je suis d'abord allé pleurer
dans les bras de papa
ensuite pendant 6 ans j'ai été invaincu
dans ma région en Qatar et en combat ce
qui m'a valu tout un tas de surnom
petite teigne terreur des tatamis et
j'en passe
premier titre de champagne de France à
12 ans entrée en équipe de France
première médaille internationale etc
c'est ça le mindset d'une championne de
karaté
bon vous attendiez peut-être une grande
nana ratée
mais mon médecin 4 j'en ai fait une
force je l'ai exploitée pour maximiser
mon potentiel
comme j'étais petite on se méfiait pas
de moi on croyait le combat gagner
d'avance
erreur car comme j'étais petite j'ai
développé d'autres compétences pour
compenser en sport la vitesse
l'explosivité l'intelligence de combat
dans la vie quotidienne la répartie la
plomb la conviction et tous les jours ça
ne sert dans mon métier
quand j'y repense combien d'adversaires
ont été surpris sans pouvoir réagir à
mes coups de poing et mes coups de pied
le kiff
aujourd'hui je taque avec les mots et
c'est tout aussi déroutant je vous
l'assure
aujourd'hui qu'un tube championne du
monde de karaté
trip championne d'Europe plus gros
palmarès mondial féminin de ma
discipline et avocate donc
des résultats dont je suis fier je vous
le cache pas mais ce dont je suis la
plus fière en réalité c'est de tout le
chemin parcouru pour en arriver là parce
que rien n'a été facile parce que j'ai
dû me battre travailler d'arrache-pied
faire plus d'efforts faire des choix
faire des sacrifices mais ce chemin m'a
forgé ce chemin m'a rendu forte
il m'a aussi appris à compter sur les
autres vous savez le fameux cercle parce
que seul on ne va nulle part
revenons un petit peu en arrière
la vraie question c'est comment
comment une petite fille de 6 ans qui
vient de se faire rabrouer par sa mère
après une mauvaise prestation
fait le choix de remettre les pieds sur
le tatami plutôt que d'abandonner ça
tombe bien c'est le sujet aujourd'hui
cercle et liberté le cercle créateur de
liberté dépasser les limites ça me parle
ça vous parle aussi j'espère
cercle et liberté deux mots de première
apparence antinomique le cercle et par
essence fermé restreint c'est quelque
chose de proche sa famille ses amis un
mentor un coach tandis que les libertés
sont infinies même si elles peuvent
parfois être lointaines et inaccessibles
liberté d'expression liberté
d'entreprendre liberté d'action
il y a autant de liberté d'action que
d'idées que de projet
que de personnes que de choix
certes les libertés et si l'un n'allait
pas sans l'autre et si les deux se
nourrissaient mutuellement
et si le cercle n'était pas une fatalité
et si l'on faisait de ce cercle une
force et si l'on s'en servait pour
atteindre les libertés que l'on convoite
issus d'une famille modeste de la classe
ouvrière mes parents sont arrêtés au
BEPC pour ceux qui connaissent l'ancien
brevet des collèges
j'ai grandi dans des HLM et mon cercle
était principalement composé de mes
parents de mes frères et sœurs de mon
grand-père et de mon professeur de
karaté petite personne ne pariait sur
moi dans le sport on disait elle
réussira pas à aller trop petite
mes propres parents ne pensaient pas une
seule seconde que je pouvais faire des
études
j'ai 17 ans je viens d'avoir mon bac
économique et social
avec mention à bien ce qui est déjà un
exploit pour ma famille
nous sommes à table et j'annonce que je
vais m'inscrire en fac de droit
mon père pouf de rire littéralement il
se moque de moi il bouffe de rire
terriblement vexé mais je lui dis tu
verras je vais y arriver
10 ans plus tard je décroche mon
certificat d'aptitude à la profession
d'avocat
la première personne que j'appelle c'est
papa
je l'ai fait je l'ai eu
par mon action par mes actions par mes
résultats par ma confiance en moi-même
par ma détermination sur le chemin j'en
ai convaincu plus d'un que mes
possibilités étaient infinies et que
je pouvais réussir tant mon projet
sportif que mon projet professionnel
donc aujourd'hui qu'un tube championne
du monde je vous l'ai dit triple
champion d'Europe et avocate donc
des résultats en effet dont je suis fier
mais le plus important comme je vous
l'ai dit c'est le chemin le chemin
parcouru pour en arriver là
cet esprit combatif je le retrouve dans
mon métier et je le mets au service
aujourd'hui de mes clients que ce soit
dans le cadre d'une plaidoirie ou dans
le cadre d'une négociation
peu importe votre cercle initial peu
importe votre milieu social et les
croyances limitantes de celui-ci chacun
est responsable de sa vie il n'y a pas
de fatalité
nous sommes libres de faire nos propres
choix nous sommes libres de tracer notre
chemin ce sont nos actions nos décisions
qui font qui nous sommes qui font qui
vous êtes
ça n'empêche pas d'exploiter les
plus-values de son cercle et il y en a
toujours des valeurs la résilience
l'ambition l'entreprenariat l'audace le
dépassement de soi l'esprit d'équipe
de la motivation du feedback du partage
d'expérience de la contradiction
peu importe l'intention ou la pertinence
des propos
peu importe le succès et l'échec la
bienveillance ou la dureté des personnes
qui vous entourent vous pouvez choisir
ce que vous voulez en faire
vous pouvez choisir vous en servir pour
vous propulser vers votre objectif
le caractère bon ou mauvais des
événements n'a pas tant d'importance que
la manière dont vous décidez de les
utiliser
le truc c'est de pas prendre un
événement ou une situation comme étant
bonne ou mauvaise de ne pas la
cataloguer mais plutôt d'identifier un
mode d'emploi un mode d'emploi qui va
vous permettre d'avancer dans toutes les
situations parce que vous pourrez pas
tout maîtriser vous pourrez pas tout
contrôler de la même façon que vous ne
pourrez pas toujours réussir
voici le mode d'emploi que j'ai trouvé
et qui a fonctionné pour moi que ce soit
dans le sport ou dans les études et
niveau professionnel 1 fixez-vous un
objectif sur le long terme qui vous
voulez être où vous voulez aller
ensuite plusieurs objectifs d'étapes à
court et moyen terme qui sont finalement
vos raisons de vous lever le matin plus
c'est précis plus c'est concret et aura
du sens 2 organiser vos actions autour
de ces objectifs votre succès vous
appartient c'est à vous de le façonner
de le créer personne ne le fera à votre
place
pour y parvenir n'hésitez pas à demander
de l'aide 3 entourez-vous de personnes
qui vont vous aider sur la route qui
vont vous aider à avancer sur la route
qui vont entretenir votre motivation qui
vont vous challenger quand vous en aurez
besoin qui vont vous apporter de la
contradiction quand vous en aurez besoin
et qui vont surtout vous aider à
surmonter les échecs parce que il y en
aura il y en aura c'est évident
et contrairement à ce que vous pensez
l'échec est un cadeau l'échec est un
cadeau il vous permet de grandir et de
passer des caps
4 la vie est un marathon pas un sprint
faites preuve de patience et accepter
que ça puisse prendre du temps même si
parfois ça prend plus de temps que prévu
nous sommes au printemps 2021 c'est la
fin de ma carrière d'athlète de haut
niveau donc j'ai déjà un palmarès
conséquent et en ligne de mire mon
dernier objectif dans cette discipline
décrocher une qualification pour les
Jeux Olympiques je suis déjà titrée
expérimenté une athlète reconnue de ses
pairs et pourtant pourtant
j'ai traversé la période la plus
éprouvante et compliquée de toute ma
carrière
pour la toute première fois j'ai été
violemment confronté au doute à l'échec
à la peur de l'échec mais vous savez
cette peur paralysante qui vous empêche
d'exploiter votre potentiel
à l'entraînement j'étais une tueuse une
des meilleures si ce n'est la meilleure
toute catégorie confondue mais en
compétition je passais à côté je perdais
tous mes moyens et je perdais des
combats contre des adversaires qui
avaient un niveau inférieur au mien
mes parents mes coachs plus personne me
comprenait je me suis sentie tellement
seule
c'est la qu'une amie m'a envoyé un lien
vers un webinaire
un webinaire de présentation d'une
nouvelle méthode de préparation mentale
je m'inscris mais sans grande
convictions parce que j'étais persuadée
d'avoir un bon mental et d'avoir toutes
les clés en main
à l'issue du webinaire je
organise un rendez-vous avec le
préparateur mental
et lors de notre première entretien il a
mis le doigt il a mis le doigt sur ma
peur irrationnelle de ne pas décrocher
cette qualification olympique et je me
souviens même lui avoir dit c'est le
drame de ma vie si j'y arrive pas
il m'a convaincu de mon besoin
d'accompagnement et j'ai donc mis mon
ego de côté j'ai mis mon ego de côté et
j'ai décidé d'investir sur moi dans
cette préparation
quand vous êtes face à une impasse que
vous n'avez pas de solution
rappelez-vous que vous avez aussi des
ressources en externe un ami un livre un
webinar une soirée TEDx
pour vous aider à débloquer la situation
en quelques séances j'ai été libéré d'un
poids
j'ai compris que si j'ai joué c'était ok
que c'était ok que j'avais le droit
que je devais le faire pour moi et que
quoi qu'il arrive à la fin mon cercle il
serait toujours là et finalement c'est
ça le plus important
s'épanouir au travers de nos actions
grâce à ce cercle si précieux pour
ajouter notre pierre à l'édifice qui est
le monde
aujourd'hui j'ai 34 ans j'adore toujours
gagner mais je ne triche plus au jeu et
j'accepte d'échouer dans tous les cas
moi et mon médecin4 on avance je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]